[Musique]
cher monsieur corps monfils palais a été
enlevé par les loups il ya trois jours
au village personne ne veut les chasser
le marié va bientôt rentrer de la guerre
[Musique]
il faut que j'ai quelque chose à
démontrer
[Musique]
alors vous allez le cuit celui qui a
pris mon fils je suis venu pour vous
aider si je le peux trouver une
explication
si le temps s'était pas la première fois
que les nouveau-nés le flanc de la
colline était couvert de morceaux de
cadavres voilà ce qu'on a en
interrogeant les villageois
allez assez pour que des gens meurent
[Musique]
et c'est nous avec nos dément c'est vous
qui avez trouvé mon fils oui vous
ressusciter les morts non monsieur
alors j'ai pas de questions corps
vous avez encore jamais vu un truc
pareil
les comportementaliste appelle ça à
fente issad on parle pas d'animaux là
monsieur corps si vous le dites
[Applaudissements]
aucune idée de ce qu'il y a de la gueule
comment elle ferait pas
quand dieu
ok
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]